tristan thompson we now know who your
number one fan is
true i want to see your little outfit
khloe kardashian posted
this adorable video to her instagram
stories monday night
the 36 year old tv star was having a
girls night in bed with two-year-old
daughter true
and someone playing on the nba game on
tv looked a little familiar
yep true recognized her favorite boston
celtics player why
of course her dad tristan thompson and
her heartwarming reaction
said it all what my daddy yeah
oh it's a commercial now he'll come back
the proud dad later posted the video to
his instagram and wrote
love my tutu the glasses
yeah come on you see how it looks oh
look at the smartphone everyone cheat
off on the test thank god you
test
following tristan's signing to the
celtics in november spending time apart
hasn't been easy for the couple who had
just rekindled their romance last year
following his cheating scandal with
jordan woods
you know things happen and of course i'm
sorry and apologetic as much as i can be
and
you know a source told e.t in december
that tristan being in boston has been
hard for chloe
but that she's quote doing her best to
keep her head up
and stay positive it's a beautiful thing
in january et learned that chloe has
been splitting her time between
boston and la with a source telling us
they're doing well as a couple and
continuing to focus
on raising true together and be the best
parents that they can be
as always i'm having so much fun with
her
in 2019 chloe told e.t she didn't have
any immediate plans to expand their
family
who do you think will have another baby
next
not me i was gonna kill you definitely
not maybe chloe
oh you said yesterday you wanted another
video maybe i said if the situation is
right
true and i don't like right now i'm
super content with just true
yeah and again i guess just i have to
see on the situation i don't feel
like it's kind of one and done too yeah
and i never thought i would have only
one child but i am so obsessed with her
and i love it so much i definitely
don't think i would feel incomplete if i
didn't have more
but another one would just add more love
to the house so i don't know yet
it's gonna be it's hard this is like a
family making kind of family
yeah like to just have one that goes
against everything that
is it it really is and that's the only
thing was i just
like born to believe i need to have so
many kids i don't know but i'm so happy
with just her so only time will tell
[Music]